this is the first podcast i've done this
year where we had tears
um and not just once and uh i don't
really know how to introduce this
conversation
i guess i guess the thing i want you to
know is that things
aren't always what they seem and um
really that humans will feel the same we
all feel the same emotions the same
peaks the same troughs
and no matter what it looks like on the
the outside
things aren't always what they seem i'm
stephen bartlett and this is the diver
ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
visualization that's a very relevant
word
i think to start this conversation
because in our last conversation last
year
when i asked you what you wanted to be
remembered for what you wanted to do
next in your career
you told me that you wanted to have a
legacy
for getting kids all across this country
up
exercising and really into exercise sort
of similar to how jamie oliver
completely changed the way we view like
school dinners and things and i remember
jamie oliver was the reason i was eating
apples instead of mars bars when i was
younger
and then just like a couple of months
later
the pandemic happens and you're getting
millions and millions of kids in this
country
up dancing and into exercise
only a couple months later it like
boggles my mind i've never seen someone
say something so big such a big ambition
and then only like a couple of months
later do it on a scale which nobody has
ever done it before
that's what happened i remember when we
met and we talked about that moonshot
thing the idea of like
having a goal so big and so outreach
that you feel you can never you know
almost never attain it and
that was my vision it was to have that
legacy of making an impact you know and
i do think about james he's had amazing
success as a chef as a
you know an author but i think about the
jamie's school dinners the man who went
into the schools all over the uk
and said look this isn't this isn't
enough our kids can eat healthier and i
feel the same about school fitness and
exercise and pe
not just about obesity and the diabetes
thing but i think about our children's
mental health
and i said to you that i want to have a
legacy where i can create
absolute you know national change and
national um
create awareness around fitness and you
know lockdown happened and within
you know 18 weeks that happened so it
was almost like a 10-year dream
happened in 18 weeks and i'm so proud of
that i've reached that many people
take me to the start so lockdown happens
where does this idea come from like what
what happens how does and then
i want to hear like when you saw the
numbers the amount of people tuning in
every day
and the impact it was having how did all
of that feel it was an intense
moment in time but it was also something
i did visualize and i did
i had been working on so i'd been
visiting schools i'd on the uk tour
i went to ireland northern ireland i'd
visited schools i'd worked out with
hundreds of kids
in these schools and that monday i was
supposed to go on another tour me and
nikki were going to take the camera you
know it's my brother nikki
um and like i've always said there was
no tv show there was no money there was
no budget it was just me and nikki
going and doing what we love which is
connecting and i suppose reconnecting
with the mission and purpose that i have
because when it's all digital i do
sometimes feel like it's just numbers
and is it
is it real people so i have to go and
visit the schools and actually meet the
kids and do it
so on the monday i was supposed to go
out on the road we had about 15 schools
chosen
and boris announced you know there's
going to be this lockdown so
it was 12 15 a.m i was laying in bed on
the thursday night
and i text nikki because i looked at my
whatsapp the next day and i text nikki
saying i've got this idea
and honestly i saw everything i saw a
hashtag i saw a logo i saw the name
i said it's going to be called pee with
joe every day next week do it let's just
try it for a week nine a.m
um monday to friday i announced it and
loads of pr you know loads of school
newsletters
you know school news letters or twitter
tweeting it and i was doing espn cnn
like global pr and i thought this is
going to be really big
but still had no idea how many people
would tune in on a monday
and on the monday we went live i stepped
in front of that camera and i was really
nervous
and 850 000 i think it was live streams
and i thought wow if you think about how
many kids that could possibly be and
then day two was the biggest one so day
two
was 954 000 live streams which is a
world record it turns out yeah
concurrently it was almost a million
people watching at the same time
yeah it blew my mind then i i realized
there and then that that was like
families that was kids it was schools it
wasn't like individual people so really
it was probably tens of millions of
people a day
and i felt this amazing sense of purpose
like i was there for people that when
they needed me the most because
everyone was locked in you know whether
you had children or not you were like
confined you felt restricted your mental
health was going to suffer that day
and i was there like to to be there and
just have fun and i never once one thing
i was really cautious of
never mentioned lockdown never mentioned
covid or the or you know
anything to do that was like it was a
safe 30 minutes where we could forget
about things
i put the music on we were dancing
around being really silly and
that was a gift that was my gift to the
world it was just a bit of laughter
some feel good energy and a real boost
in their mood when that finished i know
that they were happier
and you must have got a lot of calls
from the big sort of production
companies and tv companies wanting to
like buy it or
or to bring it to tv right within a few
days so you remember i told you the
story about the channel 4 thing i was
trying my hardest to make
the uk tour thing and a documentary
around schools fitness but they never
had the budget that no one could do it
well within a few days the head of
channel 4 like the top guy i can't think
of his name
called me up personally said joe what
you're doing is amazing we'd love you to
stream the workouts on channel four and
i
i was like dude like i'm doing this on
youtube i've got kids in sri lanka and
south america and india
and like even like madagascar and the
maldives taking part in these workouts
i can't do this on channel 4 i need to
be global and i'm so glad i stuck with
that
because that really allowed it to go
globally it allowed everyone
all over the world to take part and
don't forget i was getting a million
live streams but by the end of the 24
hours there was seven
eight million views crazy so total 80
million views on the 18 weeks so 80
million
individual views but how many families
or schools are doing that so it's tens
of millions of kids and
that was my dream so i just can't
believe it happened but
i'd built up that trust over eight years
you know as the body coaches joe wicks
as this mission driven person anyone
could have the same idea
but maybe they wouldn't have had the
same reaction because like i said i put
out so much love and energy and
positivity and visiting these schools
that
those teachers knew i was going to live
deliver a really fun and safe session
for their kids
18 million people is you know when you
sat down with me last year we had this
conversation you said you wanted to to
do this nationally right
you said you want to get kids exercising
nationally
there's only about 60 million people in
the uk you managed to do
80 million people all around the world
on a global level but also at a time
when people really needed that kind of
energy the most at a time when the
country was you know fearful
and people were trapped indoors and not
exercising
as much as they they could have been so
i you know
we can talk about the the p with joe
thing for a long time but the thing that
actually fascinates me
more is what happens afterwards
so you've just that goal you set out to
achieve you achieved it
quick how does it feel after
well you talk about that gold medal
syndrome you know of people having this
like coming off tour or coming to back
from the olympics and they have this
kind of feeling of like feeling flat or
not depressed maybe but confused and
lost and that's what happened i moved
into this new house
and i thought i've got this lovely house
why am i feeling flat and for the first
two weeks i was there
i was missing my old house in richmond
because my children were born there
p which i was in that living room that
you interviewed me in and it was like
this
i left this energy behind and moved into
this new life and i was like why am i
feeling like this and i realized it was
because
i'd lost my purpose i'd been
disconnected from that audience every
day
um so when i felt that the first thing i
do
i jump on my instagram like i said to
you i used to do dms and voice notes
and i reconnect with the messages i read
the youtube comments so that
i know two million people a month for
doing youtube workouts before the
lockdown
i'm now getting six to seven million
views a month so that's real people that
have changed
their habits they're still doing it um
and it reminded me why i did it and also
i had wonderful letters i had two two or
two or three
i'm gonna say it's probably nearly like
two or three thousand like letters and
cards and things that seems mad but i
had this stack of
things to go through so i sat in my
office for two days
you know laughing crying like feeling
this love it was like this wave of love
when i realized
what i'd actually done during that time
it wasn't just about me getting kids
exercising it was like
widows it was single parents it was
people with anxiety and depression
living on their own and
in all the all the different places in
the world it was really emotional so i
did feel lost
but i've reconnected with that because
now i'm still doing my youtube workouts
i'm still delivering free content
and although there's this new product in
this app coming out i'm so passionate
and committed to doing that one workout
a week
that i will never neglect that free
content and that audience that are there
that still may never buy my app on my
books
you talked about buying a new house
probably a bit of a dream come true in
many senses
um but again you speak about it being
kind of anti-climactical like in like
not feeling like that expectation that
when you've got that big house because
i've seen the house
it's a nice house you should have felt
like confetti should have come down and
you should have felt amazing and
but you kind of described it like you
didn't feel that like that yeah i kind
of thought you know
i was i was gonna move anyway but it was
like the the the lock down accelerated
because we had paparazzi outside and i
wasn't used to that you know i wasn't
used to being
having like folks taking a meaning when
we walked to the park and we lived on a
main road so it's quite public and
people would knock and and sort of say
hello and it was fine but sometimes you
just want a little bit of privacy like
when you switch off
so we found this lovely house and it's
you know it's got a nice driveway it's
got a beautiful back garden
and when i was in there i just kind of
thought why aren't i double as happy
i've got more space
i've got more garden but i genuinely
felt like i left
that part of me behind in that house
that was so purpose-driven it was all
about pee with joe it's where my kids
were born
so i suppose it's a lesson and i really
talked about that when boris announced
the lockdown number two and i'm sitting
there in my kitchen i've got all this
space i'm thinking
it doesn't matter if you've got a
massive house we live in a one bedroom
flat we all feel the same right now
we all feel very disconnected very
lonely you know we miss our friends and
family we need to socialize we need
events we need live music we need
dinners
so so it's just a really important
message that it doesn't matter what
situation you're in we're all feeling
the same and i really wanted to share
that message and it definitely helped
people
open up the conversation because we're
all struggling you know mentally with
this
with what's going on and yeah you know
you've talked about it before you know
ordering the car and the house
and i think we're driven by these things
and consumerism like we we're always
wanting the next thing
but what i've realized you're in this
lockdown is i'm happy exactly where i am
with just what i've got
and that's a nice feeling it's really
nice when you realize that another rolex
another car
even another motorbike or another
holiday it doesn't it doesn't give you
what you really think and i think people
listening that
are desperate for that life i think we
all come to the same conclusion
eventually whether you're 30 or 60
we will all level out and realize that
what's important is our friends and our
connection and
our love to the people around us it's it
as you say it took me a long time to
learn that lesson and
i the the phrase that i was having 27
aren't you something like that yeah you
ain't taking that long
you've got i think you're very when i
listen to your podcast i think you've
got a lot of wisdom i think you've
spoken to a lot of people and you've
you've absorbed a lot and i think you've
really taken into your own
um your own life and philosophies i
think i think you know what i think it
is i i've also been
really like self-analytical as in i will
have a thought and i'll have a feeling
and i'll try and grab onto it and hold
that out in front of me and go why are
you feeling like that so the day
as you kind of alluded to there where i
realized i was going to be very wealthy
and i start looking at cars and houses
i get this feeling of like the feeling
you described with your old house which
is
i think if i get this i'll actually feel
poorer in some way
i'll lose something like if i and then i
thought to myself well if i get this one
what's next if you get a lamborghini
aventador the the best [ __ ] sports
what's next and then i was like i'm
gonna just keep go and then me realizing
that
if i if i always start believe that my
happiness was somewhere else in a
promotion
in a new car in a big house it will
never be here
if i believe that i can't possibly be
happy because i don't have x
i will never be happy because once i get
x it's like a mirage or a rainbow it
just moves out further in front of you
yeah and you see that with a lot of
celebrities a lot of musicians like
talented people that get everything so
young you know they get to that point
where
they start you know they go into
depression and anxiety and it can you
know manifest in drug addiction or
you know all kinds of things but yes if
you're constantly looking for the next
thing
or almost living in the past with old
memories and what you used to have like
you talk about
down contrasting and up contrasting like
that thing you said
changed my life just thinking stop
thinking about what you did last year
how you went to america and you went to
coachella
think about what you're doing today and
not worrying about that and it really
just brings you to a it's like a medita
it's like a meditation it's a
thought a simple thought where you can
actually start to bring yourself back to
the moment and
like like i said i it could be a quote
it could be a podcast it could be an
interview
little things just sometimes it opens up
a whole new thought process isn't it
and you start to think actually you know
what that's amazing and also
i interviewed fern cotton and she said
one of these lovely quotes is
nothing in nature blooms all year round
you know where we're constantly
i need number one podcast i need the
number one app i need to have
um you know the best book i need
everything's got me number one i need to
be doing everything every month for the
year but i've realized that
in nature like nothing blooms all year
round and that again made me realize
it's okay to have quiet months and not
be in the media
chill out relax because something good
will come late on a year you'll bloom
again and during summer
and i think so little things like that
really open up my mind and
i'm evolving quickly i think since i
become a parent as well um you start to
be much more empathetic and you start to
understand and you feel a lot more when
you've got kids i don't know where it
comes from but
i'm i think a lot more about other
people's feelings now more than i ever
used to
i actually wrote down um when i was
watching your video that you did during
the lockdown where you start discussing
your own mental health and you saying
i've just watched boris's announcement
and i'm feeling really [ __ ] but in that
video you also say
i'm feeling [ __ ] at the thought that
there's loads of families out here that
are going to lose their jobs and stuff
and i wrote in my notes
right like incredibly empathetic like
you are incredibly empathetic and it
kind of it made me question like
where did he get that from because that
is a trait i noticed in you last time as
well
most people in the middle of a lockdown
when they just found out that we're
going into
our second lockdown don't think oh my
god all these other people that are
going to lose their jobs
and you i could see it in your face and
i know you're a genuine guy because i've
been with you we've gone for dinner you
know outside of the podcast i know who
you are
i'm like he genuinely genuinely cares i
think it's grown him i think that
feeling has grown in me
but where i used to be like you know
when you're a teenager you're a young
adult it's all about you it's like me me
me
and then you you know you find a partner
and you start to realize it's about your
partner and it's about your kids but
i think yeah like the more i realize
that we're all connected it's that thing
of connection you know
it comes from sometimes a meditation or
a feeling of like
we're all we're all in the same
experience and you know
i've had i've been very lucky like the
body coach brand has grown you know my
youtube audience has grown like the sign
ups of the planet
it's all gone insane and so i think
about other people in small business i
genuinely care about fact i think about
families that have run like restaurants
for 30
years or had you know properties or had
like amazing nightclubs or
you know amazing restaurants that are
suddenly going under like that it
affects me and that
really when i stop and think about all
the pain and suffering in the world it
really brings me down
it really kind of brings my energy down
and then i have to kind of exercise or
do something positive because i start to
feel a bit
sad because that is the world right now
you know there's billions of people that
are going for a really difficult time
and so my reaction to that is
trying to inspire them to move to eat
well to exercise because i know that it
can counteract
any kind of you know financial pressures
or stress that's going on
if you exercise and you lift your energy
and you and you put good food in your
body
you know even temporarily you're going
to feel better and it's going to change
your mind so
that's my gift you know i try and
inspire people to exercise and feel good
for
you know even if it's once a day or once
a week it's enough to change the way you
feel about yourself and your life
we went from a little dinner a couple a
couple of months back i don't know
i think just after the first lockdown
before the second one um and
i was i came home really inspired on one
end but just
i couldn't shake this thought and i i
hate to go back to it but i couldn't
shake this idea
that you just had the biggest
achievement of your life
with this p i mean outside of your kids
in my opinion
um out with this p with joe format that
just shook just spread across the world
right
and the joe i met at that dinner was
somewhat despondent as you say like
confused
and um as you say like really unsure
about why you weren't feeling on top of
the world and also really unsure about
what you do next to
to kind of like top that i guess and it
really stayed with me
it stayed with me for like a couple of
weeks what did you think do you think
i'd be more like
energetic and and and proud and like
ambitious or what
every every person on planet earth would
have thought okay so joe set out to
achieve something and he smashed it out
the park
he is on all of the tv stations
congratulations on the mbe by the way
that's a whole nother conversation we'll
get to that
mad he smashed everything at the park
um he's got to be just absolutely
buzzing we were sat at the dinner
and there's people coming up to us
asking you for pictures halfway through
the dinner as well
but you weren't like that and even
though i've written about this in my
book at great length about gold medal
syndrome and gold medal depression and
my own experiences
i still when i saw that in you i was
like [ __ ]
people need to hear about this because
you were i'll be honest right
that was the lowest i've ever seen you
really oh yeah
i suppose i i was concerned no i mean
look i was i was really looking forward
to seeing you and i was it was i was you
know we hadn't been out for a while but
i think
coming off the back of that pee with joe
i was emotionally drained i think you
know physically i can do workouts all
day i've done it
dude i've done a 24-hour workout like i
can move my body
but i think the energy of performing
like going on stage stepping in front of
the camera
when i wasn't in the mood for it when i
had to like pick up every
i was literally carrying everyone's
emotion and energy and trying to and i
do believe in energy that we carry and
we push it and we sometimes hold
negative energy we sometimes
hold things locked up from years ago and
i was just i suppose
fatigued emotionally fatigued at that
point but i've bounced back you know i'm
back in the zone i'm filming workouts
again and i'm um
i'm refocused like i said on the on the
purpose and the mission which is like
fitness rule and i've got the app is one
option i've got the books there's one
option but then also
instagram youtube you know there's so
much free content because
i don't want anyone to feel like the
body coaches premium brand and i can
only get him through that paid
subscription
no i'm still gonna give you one workout
a week on youtube and i'm still gonna do
my instagram recipes i'm still gonna
share
my daily stories and motivate you um and
every now and again
i might mention the app but it really is
just like for people that want to give
it that extra push you know and try
something a bit different
so as we park pee with joe you know last
time you sat down here you
put out into the world your your goal
your ambition and it came true
so i think you know let's tempt again uh
what is your what is your
goal and ambition now going forward in
terms of your purpose
well i think what i what what happened i
achieved was a short-term thing you know
it changed behaviors but they had to
they had to do it because they were
locked in
parents had to keep their kids moving um
you know schools
weren't providing pee everything was
closed so it was a temporary thing
it was the start of a movement but it's
the legacy is still
continuing that movement you know
continuing to visit schools continuing
to speak to
heads and i don't see it as a government
thing because i've realized that you can
actually just speak to local schools and
they have the ability to change their
curriculum well they have to follow the
curriculum but they can change their
timetable so
if they want to fit a 15-minute workout
in once a day with their children
or do it um you know at the end of the
day they have the ability so
again it's about continuing to grow that
mission to
create content maybe it's a separate
platform which schools can use
but it isn't over because like anything
motivation drops it might
it drops for me it drops for you um
different times of the year and with
young people
they're very engaged at the early ages
in primary school but when they start
hitting their teens
they're in the devices they become more
resistant to exercise so the challenge
becomes tougher as they get older
so my mission now is to continue the
school's work
when i can go on the road start visiting
schools again creating content you know
i'm hopefully creating a tv show around
that you know like jamie over school
dinners was only six episodes in my head
it felt like it was weeks and months and
months of content
so you know i want to do the same thing
i want to create a really amazing series
whether it's um you know netflix or bbc
or channel 4
where i can continue that conversation
to get one teacher or one dinner lady or
one
um head of a school to believe in the
power of exercise for their children
so i really feel like i've just started
there's so much more to go i think you
have as well
and you know so like we what one thing
i've learned from doing this podcast and
speaking to guests like you is that
and even eddie hearn who we had on last
week is how pivotal and how defining
our early years are and you are like a
really fascinating guy in so many ways
we talked about your empathy
your achievements um all of these things
suggest
that you're because they're such
extraordinary things or out of the
ordinary things
suggest that you probably had quite an
out of ordinary
childhood whenever whenever i meet
someone uh
who is achieved out of ordinary things i
always think okay tell me about your
childhood
so how was your childhood joe oh so you
think you don't think it was a stable
child do you think they were saying a
bit more that motivated me
to yeah i think i think um and it
doesn't necessarily mean it was like a
really bad childhood or a good childhood
i always you know and i actually did
childhood psychology for two years which
people don't know about this is why i'm
so fascinated by
like all the freudians um psychology and
and how one thing that happened
i've got a friend who told me that one
thing that happened when he was a kid
he still remembers to the day to this
day and he holds that one comment
that someone in his family made to him
as the reason for his
probably his single biggest flaw in his
personality and it was just one
comment on one day from a parent yeah
that's that's that's amazing
and that's the power of um yeah the
power of a negative thought like if
someone says
your teeth are a bit crooked or you've
got skinny legs like someone could say
you've got lovely teeth your whole life
but you still think your teeth are
crooked
yeah and that's happened to me in the
past i got invisalign because one a
girlfriend said to me you know
your teeth are a bit wonky really you
know and and someone said about you know
this is a true story when i was 16 i had
glasses but i was really embarrassed i
was really shy about it and
the girl i was going out and said i said
something like i wonder if i'd look good
in glasses and she
she said oh no you'd look silly in
glasses so i never wore them for two or
three years i just hide them in my car
drive to our house take them out
and you know it's that thing of we
really take on these these thoughts and
it can really affect our confidence and
that definitely definitely happened to
me as a kid but i suppose
my childhood was very chaotic you know
it was very unstable
my dad was a drug addict from a very
young age so you know
that was it was a bit like you know he
was there one minute next minute he was
in rehab next minute he was he was back
on the gear you know and he my mum would
take him back and it was
all good and then they'd be arguing and
you know i lived in a council flat with
um
really thin doors so
it was like um it's like plywood and so
there used to be holes in the wall
there's be holes in the door because i
remember um
i need to think why are there holes in
the door like and i look back now i know
it's because mum and dad used to fight
and argue and you know it'd be like
it was a symbol of aggression and
impatience and intolerance and
then it'd be gone and so i always i
didn't have a positive role model in
terms of
in terms of a male and also when it
comes to marriage you know my mum and
dad never got married if they were
married they would have been divorced a
hundred times
so i had similar beliefs around marriage
and commitment to you like to hear you
talking about it like i
i suppose i had the same feelings when i
was 25 i didn't believe that
people stay together people are
committed that marriage is going to work
that
you know people get through tough time
because it was always like when it got
[ __ ] and tough my dad would piss off and
we'd be back on our own again so
you know again it was a tough childhood
but also i had a happy childhood i
didn't i don't feel like resentment i
don't look back and be like i wish it
was different i wish my dad was there
because we got a great relationship
today
but it definitely affected me you know
the destruction of drugs in my household
and what came with that all the chaos
really put me off
ever wanting to smoke weed or drink
alcohol you know i was so scared that i
was going to enjoy it and i was going to
become an addict i thought it was a
genetic thing i thought i don't want to
be a drug addict so i wouldn't go near
it so
it definitely um it definitely shaped me
you know and when i look at
where my love and generosity and empathy
comes from it's my mom like my mom is
she's so kind and loving and she's so
always putting other people first and i
think that definitely shaped me as
an adult i didn't actually know this
stuff about you before i didn't know
that you'd been through such a
um traumatic early childhood and
as you were saying that i was thinking
[ __ ] hell it's remarkable that you
are
who you are and that you have such
feelings of empathy and you're just
such a kind human being having gone
through
such a you know violent and traumatic
childhood and i guess that is credit to
your mum
um i suppose yeah i look back when i get
asked in interviews now like where
where did your generosity and your
kindness come from and your kind of
desire to want to help others it's about
help
you know i'm happiest when i'm helping
others so if i know i'm helping someone
or i'm helping millions
i'm really happy and so when it when it
stops i felt i'm not i'm not
i'm not i haven't got my purpose i'm not
valuable but i've realized i am still
valuable i'm still helping people
um but yeah my mum you know she left
school at 15 no qualifications
she met my dad in a squat she had my
brother when she was 17. then she had
nikki
she had me when she was 19. she's like a
kid and when we used to go play she's
like people she says that your sister
she looks so young you can't imagine
like
um but somewhere along the line she
taught me value she taught me respect
you know
if i had to be home at 10 o'clock on a
friday night i was home at ten o'clock
my mates were down apart till one two
for him because their parents let him
run loose and
they were the ones graffiti and they
were the ones smoking weed they were the
ones that got in you know in trouble for
you know crimes and whatnot so my mum
was really
considering she wasn't parented her dad
left her when she was a kid
she was she was a banner when she was a
baby so i don't know where her love
comes from but she's got this
ability to just love and and be so
generous and when she went to university
she went back she said i want to study
she
she went to become a social worker so
the first thing she'd done with her life
was going to help people that
you know young offenders people that had
been through abuse and and all this
stuff so
it has to come from her it's a motive
it's my mum so when i took my mom for
dinner um
the night before it was going to be
announced and i said to her like
we're celebrating my birthday tonight
aren't we because it's we we were having
a late birthday there but it's something
else
yeah miami and i said mom um i've got an
mba and she we're in the middle of lucky
cat
restaurant in london and she burst into
tears and i'm like
in the middle of the restaurant crying
with her and she's like when she was
younger like all her friends used to say
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] parent imagine the
pride and it is it's
she raised me like i have to put it down
to her
you talked about your dad then said you
said that you've um
after all that you'd been through and
all you'd observed and his addiction and
his battles with addiction you've got a
good relationship with him now
yeah we we do because you know addiction
never goes away like
he's you know he does his na meetings
it's a part of his life but
he he needs that he needs to have a
fellowship and a network of people to
talk to like i don't understand
addiction i've never been addicted to
anything so for me it's like
it he needs that that network of people
he can talk to and that's obviously the
moment mostly through zoom but usually
it's like n a meetings
you know you go and have a talk and you
you feel better and he's had you know he
had therapy but you know he's learned
he's
he's became he's evolved like again like
his dad left him and
i understand my mom and dad because they
went through so much trauma my mom was
abandoned when she was two years old was
living in a
she was in a um you know an orphanage
and then
my dad the same thing he's that left him
like he didn't have
you know he didn't ever say i think i
don't think my dad's
dad told him he loved him until he was
like on his deathbed when he had cancer
so like
i understand where that addiction why my
dad chose to like do that with his life
and i understand why my mum
had ocd like because i know what she
went through as a kid i know what she
went through as a young teenager and so
you start to understand it and then you
start to really love your parents even
more because they protect you when
you're a kid they're just protection
they can't tell you what they went
through they can't tell you this stuff
so it really like
makes you realize how much trauma
they've had and where that's manifested
and so now like my relationship my dad
is i understand him i understand that he
he has seasonal depression during the
winter he's really low and he'll have a
holiday and he feels great and he comes
back and he's up and down and
that's him and i just have to kind of
love him and although i'm quite
consistent with my emotions
and you want everyone around you to be
happy all the time don't you think i'll
buy him a motorbike i
send them to the maldives or you can go
and stay at my house in america it's all
temporary it's all
it doesn't do a lot you know so real
connection comes from like communicating
reaching out
spending spending time with him like
he's happy when he comes around and we
go for a walk or we got on our
skateboards together you know we've got
electric skateboards so
it's about reconnecting and being with
him and he he needs that my dad needs to
see the grandkids he needs to see
my brothers he needs to see me and um
yeah i've just learned that
like i said that really nice quote that
the the antidote to addiction is
connection not push him away
i hate you i can't stand it why are you
relapsing again why are you going into
depression
you know the mind's really complex and
you have to
understand that people aren't going to
always be how you want to be and you
have to love them unconditionally
but if you ask me as a teenager i would
be too angry i'd be like
[ __ ] that no like i can't deal with it i
don't have a dad but that's a drug
i don't speak to him i wouldn't have had
the emotional um
ability to deal with that but now as an
ad i'm 35 and i can understand it a bit
more
a little crazy because um i love that
quote by the way and it
i think johanna hari is a real uh sort
of yeah i think i've got his book on the
shelf behind me about lost connection
from yeah that's yeah i think russell
brand mentioned it to me and i thought
wow that's such a nice thought
and that's what the book is about it's
about the real reasons for depression
and anxiety fundamentally stem back to a
loss of connection of some sort
and it was telling when you were telling
your story about the generational sort
of cycle that's going on there
your mother's you know your dad and her
upbringing and then your father's
dad and how like it was a lack of
connection it seems
that put them into the situations they
were in and then
that lack of connection made them a
certain way which then nearly made
you treat them with a lack of connection
as well
and i think it seems like much of the
reason you're able to break the cycle is
because you've realized that
and you're like as you say bringing
bringing him close
despite you know i talk about this a lot
with my friends that have um
an estranged parent or have lost a
parent and i always tell them i was
doing it this week
i was saying you've got to forgive them
for
their own faults because their faults
have come from
some kind of trauma and tony robbins
says it as well he says you've got
sometimes we've got to forgive our
parents for being imperfect not being
the parents we hoped they were yeah
it's so true and like you said you you
know memories
memories can form like your literally
change your characteristics and your
personality and your belief system and
i had really negative beliefs around
commitment around um
you know people being faithful people
sticking together like when things got
tough to people
and even i'd be affected if like
celebrities that i really loved like
they'd break up i'd think
see that even they can't stay together i
just thought no one stays together no
one's loyal no one's
no one's ever like actually happily
married and stays together but now as a
married man with two kids who i love
i'm really really like i don't believe
that i believe that you can be happy i
believe that when i see an old couple on
the bench you know 78 year old couple
i love that i think how amazing they've
spent their life together i want to be
like that i want to be a couple that are
stuck together so
it's you know my child has affected my
um my my love and commitment
as a as a relate in a relationship to
rosie but also as a parent like i don't
want to be
impatient and intolerant and snappy and
swear and shout but
that is my default setting that's what
my head's trying to do when indian miley
screaming at me
i want to slam the door and walk out the
house or i want to scream and shout back
at him because that's what i
that's what i had as a kid so i have to
actively work against that so
although i might be screaming in my head
i just take a breath and i like
almost just sort of um yeah just take a
moment to just sort of
calm myself and then i can react very
differently but that is a that's a
muscle you have to train it
because otherwise i'd just be screaming
and shattering all day long
you know so that's definitely it's hard
to do that when you've had it all your
life when you just got
you know screamed that shouted at it's
just it's like what you know it's
default it's a default yeah like it
truly is like a it's like a computer
program and you have to sort of
try and undo that code um and i read a
book called um
calm calm parents happy happy kids
and it's that thing you can either fight
flight or or pause and have a breath
you can fight and swear and shout and
scream and slam the door you can
run out of the house and just deal with
it and let them deal with it and just
not even deal with any emotion
and show no emotional control or you can
pause and have a breath and that's the
secret
it's just having that right in these two
years old her brain is not rational she
can't understand why
i really want to just clean the side and
put her down on the floor right now and
so like you've got to literally remind
yourself every time
and then you can start to really respond
differently
we're all human you have days where you
you get it i have days like i mean
course i have days where i shout and
i lose the plot and i feel terrible but
also i know that
she won't hold it against me like the
amount of times i was showered at i
i love my mum to death so it's not like
she shouted at me i think she's terrible
and i don't
love her for today like i think it's
okay to not be perfect not be a perfect
parent and
the other dad had a row of rose and i
said i'm i'm sorry i'm not perfect every
day i'm sorry that some days i'm
surprised
rosie's my wife i said i'm i'm i'm sorry
that i'm not
perfect every i love you so much i'm so
affectionate and
sensitive but if i'm stressed and i've
got something gone sometimes i'm snappy
sometimes i'm impatient and
i don't shout the kids i might shout at
you and i'm sorry and
it's nice to say that out loud and have
a bit of a chat about it because then
you kind of move on and you can just
you know get on with it and you learn
from it you're getting busier right with
the app coming with the app stuff you're
doing you're getting
more requests than ever before surely
dude i'm so i've this has been the year
like i've i mean i've worked hard really
over the last years you know
during the growing stage like with
social media you know it's hard building
an audience and
then i kind of had great success with
the books and now like you know this a
year
since p with joe um the 24-hour
challenge
i i then done wake up with joe which is
three workouts a week for a lockdown two
because i thought they need to exercise
people need to move i'm i've now had the
book pr
i've been doing radio interviews i've
done the channel for so the bbc
children need 24 hour channels i've not
stopped like i don't know how i'm still
going but i now at this moment need more
energy than ever because this is the
busy time this is like
leading up to christmas i'm also doing a
january bootcamp
five days a week i'm doing live workouts
through the app you know which is great
because it means people are going to go
i want to give it a go and it's a really
amazing way of marketing the product but
i'm going to be exhausted if you think
about your state and your mood and how
you feel within yourself
in the midst of all this like chaos and
then we've got the pandemic rattling on
outside as well
what impact has it had on you um
all of this busyness and now you've got
two kids you know that are you growing
up and
screaming at you and don't want to be
put down
have you felt a change i deal with it in
different ways like usually
i have these like blocks where i'll i
work for like two three months and then
i go right i'm gonna go to santa monica
for a few weeks so
let's go and have a nice week in dubai
just to unwind and leave the phones and
stuff and
i've missed that i've missed that just
that reset button because i've had a
i'd like a couple of days away um just
when lockdown was over but it wasn't
enough because
i actually spent my time filming
workouts because i said i was gonna do
three workouts a week so although i was
there relaxing
i'm still there and my what i do is so
physical like
you know being being physical and doing
exercise but also doing if such an
amazing energy
through the camera is so draining but
last week has been
the most emotionally draining i was
doing like radio interviews with um
like jamie oliver and ricky gervais and
uh doing all these things i'm it's out
of my comfort zone completely
and then i had phone calls every every
hour on the hour to promote the new book
so
that is a different type of emotion and
when we talk about the body code so you
know i am the physical body like the
energy
and nikki is like the cto he's the
brains he takes all the stuff all the
things i can't the process stuff
nikki's on a laptop doing zoom calls
nine hours a day like managing this
agency
and all the other marketing stuff so
together we have this perfect kind of
relationship where
we are working as equally as hard but
we're taking we're doing what we can do
sure so i don't feel like burning out
but i do think at the end of january i
need to block a month out so i've taken
the month off
hoping to go you know somewhere nice
like i love costa rica i'd love to go
with the kids
amazing you know just just just unwind
and basically when i have that time
down off the offline and i'm not filming
it really re-energizes me when i come
back i'm like i'm like resetting like
body coach volume 2 ready to go again
sort of thing you talked a little bit
there about marriage earlier and you've
also
you've also heard me on this podcast
talking about marriage right i want you
to tell me
where i i'm getting it wrong yeah and
also why you think i'm getting it wrong
so i listened to two episodes of your
podcast and i
i really hear i hear myself and you when
i was like 25
and i was a lot and i feel i feel like a
part of you is lost because you've got
everything on the surface you could
possibly want you've you've smashed it
in business like
you've got an amazing story and you've
got you know incredible success which is
wonderful but there's maybe you're
missing that deeper connection with one
person
you know you've got amazing friends and
you've got a great network of people you
work but
i do feel like the love between one
person you know it's different it's a
different kind of relationship but you
can always lean on them so
when i was 25 i was in a relationship
from 19
and i really i was running away i
couldn't commit to i didn't
i used to say like exactly what you were
like this marriage is like this
religious thing it's a contract and why
should that person get half of what i've
gotten
what it's not gonna work all my other
friends are unhappy they're all divorced
you know one in three marriages
so the more you tell yourself that the
more it becomes true and the truth is
how you feel now is how you feel and
what you believe now is what you believe
but when you meet someone and you you
realize and when you do fall in love in
whatever
sense that could be it was almost like
with rosie i was telling her every day i
loved her
and it wasn't enough it was i needed to
tell her more i needed to have something
stronger between us so i said can we
have a baby
you know then she felt pregnant we had
indie so for me in my head the ultimate
bond between two humans and he's another
child
and then when she was pregnant i never
thought i would get excited about the
idea of like
proposing and getting married but it was
just it just changed my mind has changed
as i started to think
you know i love this girl i don't want
to be waking up you know
every other week with a different girl
in a different hotel i'm like that's not
who i have been and it's never who i'll
be
so i love being with i love being close
to one person i think i'm quite um
emotional right there
um and then after to marry me we had
this amazing wedding day and
i do love being mad and i just think
when you have kids and you start seeing
your children grow and you
you see how wonderful that can be how
much joy they bring you i just think
your perspective will change over time
and
you're just not there yet it might you
might not get that till you're 35 you
could be
45 i was 30. i met rosie at 30. okay and
i've been the happiest since i turned
30.
honestly i've just been i'm commit
because being being honest
and being committed is two of the most
wonderful things being sneaky being
deceitful not being honest or being
jealous and insecure they're feelings
you do not want to go through your life
with
so when you find someone you know be
committed and be loyal it's a really
it really takes your love to another
level you believe in the you know
there's a bunch of words people use in
uh
in this in this realm of like love and
marriage uh they say you know
you gotta find your soul mate i don't
know if it's soulmate but
everyone says oh hard you know loves
hard work marriage is hard work it isn't
it doesn't have to be hard work not if
you're with the right person of course
you could get with someone too young
marry the wrong person it all goes wrong
and you know that's a bad experience but
it doesn't mean that the next
relationship won't be better and you
can't improve and learn from it
but you know i do feel like rosie is is
the kind of female version of me like
when we met you know we were just having
so much fun and
she's she's a wonderful parent i watch
her and i see how patient she is i think
i learn a lot from her because
i i've got like a two or three minute
kind of
tolerance of marley screaming and
screaming in my face where i just have
to walk out the room i just can't handle
it whereas
she can be in there like 20 minutes all
through the night and i'm like because
yeah with indie crying or marley
teething i think it's amazing she's just
got this natural
innate like motherly patience and love
and tolerance so i watch that and i
literally like go i need a bit more of
that and i sort of learn from it
but yeah i mean you know maybe maybe you
might have one relationship last five
years but i do believe that
when you are in a relationship like give
it all don't don't be thinking this is
going to end soon this
my last one didn't work out i know now
it's going to break down and we're going
to end up breaking apart we're gonna end
up leaving each other
she'll have an affair i'll i'll leave
her it won't work that just it's hard to
be happy in that
situation so i think take every
relationship
and just maximize it to the best of your
ability like you would with
someone that you were of a business
partner if we went into business
together you're trying to
try and make that partnership so like
awesome and so effective and efficient
and
it's the same with a relationship you've
got you know keep keep
keep doing the things that make you
happy and and yeah i think with rosie
like just having a night out going for
dinner
um and the you know the secret is if you
stop kissing you're [ __ ]
if you don't kiss your girlfriend and
you stop kissing you just bypass each
other
and you don't because everything starts
from a kiss i mean
it could become a massage it could
become you know you might do a
bit of hanky-panky but if you stop
kissing that one thing that intimacy
i feel like i feel like everything
breaks down seriously
can you kiss him it's one of the it's
probably the only thing that i've
thought about
going and seeing a therapist about is
like i have a fairly
negative pessimistic let's say
perception
on romantic relationships um and i think
i've identified that
on one hand i'm my expectations are
probably like
somewhat unm unmutable and then on the
other hand
i kind of see relationships as being
like a bird in a cage
is the best way where does that come
from like so i know your mom and dad and
they're
arguing at each other my parents that's
the only th that's the only
marriage role model in your your base
and your opinion on yeah so i i have
these v
but when i say my parents screamed at
each other i'm like my mum
i've never seen since a human able to
perform
this screaming match she did nigerian
woman if you don't know nigerian women
i do visualize it like around the
kitchen table the sound is un
like you've never seen my dad actually
said one day he said i your mom was
screaming at me this is i think when we
lived in manchester probably before i
was born
your mum was screaming at me and i went
out
like went shopping did all that she had
no idea i came back and she's still
screaming she had no idea that i'd left
the house
and the the the the sound of it
i i have this like mental image of my
dad sat passively just this like
passive white guy just sat there
watching tv just looking at the screen
and my african mother like kind of stood
above him just
bellowing into his face at full volume
for like six
hours she didn't lose energy we talked
about like exhausting yourself
she didn't lose her energy and she would
follow him around the house
and so i looked at my dad and thought
he's trapped
and this is what my you know that that
experience of seeing your mum shout is
that effect is that like affected your
you know your
you know when you argue are you
confrontational are you like because me
and rosie more like silent tree and we
sulk and we're so stubborn and we'll
like go two days without talking
we don't scream and shout each other you
are you quite shallow i will never shout
i see you're calm
never i will not do it i i will the
minute so
i will try and explain myself in a very
calm way and then i'm like okay i'm
going
right away i will like do you ever say
sorry do you ever admit you're wrong
or do you find it hard for me so if
you'd asked me that question two years
ago the answer would have been like no i
never say sorry like because i always
kind of think i'm right and it's like my
way or the highway
in the last year and when i was i got
with this certain person
um who i won't name and
she kind of taught me to like grow up a
little bit and and
i started to apologize for things
and i started to learn to apologize a
little bit more but i'm i've got to be
honest i'm not going to lie it's like
the whole point of this podcast is not
to [ __ ] lie like
i'm still not that good at it it is hard
i'm the same i find it hard to say sorry
in the moment
but i do if i go away for a little half
an hour an hour have a walk or do a
workout i do come back and i go
i was a bit disrespectful there i do
apologize but yeah it's an ego thing
it's like you just gotta let your guard
down
one thing i say about relationships
which i really think is valuable i can't
remember where i heard it i read it but
it was about
you can be in a relationship with
someone and this expectation thing where
you
want them to do everything perfect and
be everything in one and be like this
amazing like
just like unicorn right but you might
find them really attractive and really
funny but intellectually they just don't
challenge you just you can't have
conversations about what they don't
understand you but
you can ring me or nicky and we you can
get that that that that part of a
relationship with from someone else so
there's no pressure on that person
you're with to like be really
intelligent really understand business
and really understand social media like
that's something i've learned that
sometimes you have to love the person of
what they've got
you know love they're they're really
affectionate love that they're really
caring considerate but
maybe other elements of their
personality you have to get from someone
else because
the chances of you finding the unicorn
it's so rare isn't it
that you're going to find that and also
you like you might be amazing at certain
things but you might not be good at one
yeah i'm not a unicorn this is the
problem
who is he from no wonder no one's a
unicorn really no one's completely
perfect because
when you're in a relationship you want
the other person to like you know do
everything like you and
it'd be interesting the same things you
like rosie's not into
you know motorbikes but i got my brother
and my my my little brother george and
my dad so i kind of get i scratch that
itch and i come back and then i spend
time with rosie and the kids so it's
really about finding the needs that you
need as a human being
in in maybe in multiple people and then
you can really just focus on what you
love about your partner
it does help you talk to a little i
talked a little bit about that about
going to therapy have you ever gone to
therapy
so this week i had my deadline for my
book happy sexy millionaire which you
can now pre-order
and it's been an absolute
labor of love over the last couple of
years and because
i had the deadline on sunday i was head
down
smashing it out um typically like me
forgetting to
eat my meals and things like that and um
and this is where he all saved me once
again and i was in my office until 6 a.m
in the morning
i was getting very very tired i had two
heels
and um i had dinner as well and it's for
me that was the perfect
that was the reason why i've teamed up
with huel because
someone like me in that situation would
basically either completely skip meals
i would not get my sort of vitamins and
minerals i wouldn't get protein
then i'd start feeling like [ __ ] um
because i didn't have
the time and that's as i've said in this
podcast before the reason
i've um i'm so attached to huell the
company the brand the
the founder julian because it really
does save my ass and it has done for
three years and if you ask someone like
me
you know that does have uh a very
time limited life then i really really
recommend you give huel a shot i really
recommend you you give
berry flavour huel a shot because that
is my favorite flavor
and um yeah so this week i just wanted
to shout out because you definitely
saved me on sunday
when i had my book deadline and also go
and check out my book happy sexy
millionaire
it's quite nice it's like um
yeah it's nice
i talked a little bit about that about
going to therapy have you ever gone to
therapy
i call it the gym but yeah i think my
therapy from a kid and i look back
like for sure like i was stressed i
didn't want to go home
i would be always out the house always
playing sport i think it was my therapy
and i dealt with things through sport
and
maybe that's why i became the body coach
but i think
i had um i had one therapy session with
a counselor at once um
because i was basically in a
relationship i didn't want to be in and
i needed to talk to someone about it
and i had that session and i i just
spoke and and verbalized everything i
was going through
and it was almost like just by saying i
was like i know i need to walk away from
this now and i
i went home and that was it so it was a
re it was an investment it was like an
hour of my time
um i i spoke to someone because it
wasn't my mum who's invested my dad who
has invested it wasn't her parents and
my friends who really cared about her it
was like a completely neutral person
and it really helped because it changed
the rest of my life because i left a
relationship i wasn't happy in
i met rosie i got married and i had kids
you know and this is the situation i was
19 when i met that girl
i was backpacking i was in a bar in
australia you're very different
10 years later so maybe maybe there can
be such thing as a relationship that's
really great at a certain time in your
life
but then when it's not right and it
isn't working having a child and
marrying that person is definitely the
wrong thing to do
and i didn't really realize that until i
met rosie just how
how unhappy i probably was in that last
relationship
so yeah i've had it once and i think if
i n
if i feel like i need it i'd be open to
it i've got a lot of friends that do it
it's like i see it as like personal
training for the mind isn't it it's like
why not why not take care of your brain
and your heart and your mind and that
can be done through therapy so i'm open
to it
um i just haven't felt i haven't had the
calling i'm more interested in um
i really like the idea of doing an ios
ceremony can we do it together do you
know why i'm just i
listen to your podcast i listen to like
certain people that do it and i
i'm drawn to it because of that gateway
and opening up that even more love and
more connection when you realize
we're all so interconnected and
obviously you can meditate for 10 years
or you can go and do an rsc ceremony and
apparently you get it's like a fast
track
to that feeling but yeah you've talked
about it have you have i mean i was in
mexico and tulum and they they were
doing like peyote
ceremonies out there and i i just
couldn't quite convince enough to do it
but i would love to do ayahuasca one day
like go proper into the amazon do it
properly with a shaman
and like you know feel feel that mother
nature they talk about that feeling of
like the earth and
that are connected to the human race it
must be a wonderful feeling have you
ever done mushrooms
i've never done mushrooms now i've never
i've never done drugs so i couldn't
really um
i've never done anything like that i've
never done mushrooms or ayahuasca but i
the more sorry i've just i've just
invested almost a million dollars into
a psychedelic company that's using it to
kill men's health disorders we talked
about this didn't we
yeah for the psilocybin so my dad was
involved in the trials um the imperial
college london he's involved
he was basically um one of the uh not
the guinea pigs but yeah he
it was a trial between psilocybin um a
placebo and an antidepressant drugs and
obviously the the studies come back that
like
this can really help and it's a natural
it's a natural product from the
from the earth so yeah i can see that
growing in the next few years for sure
when it when it gets appropriate has it
been approved in the u.s for like
yes it's impression and stuff um don't
quote me on this but uh
it's an it's in the final stage of fda
approval psilocybin so it's very very
close
and there's a company called compass
pathways which has just gone public and
is
as of right now worth about two billion
which is really dive sort of leading the
pack and developing psilocybin but
it's crazy that i've not tried it but
i've looked at all the
research and development videos and
studies and data and it like
blow blew my mind are you are you
tempted to try yourself are you
scared and nervous about it cause i know
the numbers i've been through
i've looked at every drug and i've seen
where mushrooms and psilocybin
um rank in terms of the harm they could
possibly do to you and the harm they can
do to others
when you're on them it's below alcohol
it's blown like every it's at the bottom
it's the bottom thing on the list
yeah it's been shown to really um really
help with addiction and depression and
trauma from that so
yeah i suppose i wonder what experience
about for us who maybe we're not
depressed and we're not anxious i wonder
what that experience would be like but
yeah you know i listened to a lot of
podcasts you know tim
ferriss is big on it rogan you know yeah
it's just kind of it feels like this
scary thing but
it's because it's been going on for
thousands of years you know we've kind
of tribes and
it's not some dirty chemical drugs been
manufactured in the lab i think it
it's non-addictive it opens up so what
they say is it opens up like
neurological pathways that
maybe is all these memories locked did
you hear the tim ferriss podcast he said
like
he'd done an ayahuasca ceremony or maybe
it was psilocybin and
he had this vision of trauma that came
through that he completely blocked out
really
yeah so he got he experienced them child
abuse like he
literally didn't remember it and he had
this vision and all these memories of
being abused and it like completely like
opened up
his mind he's now obviously sharing
about it but that was like something
so it's quite in a way you don't know
what you're unlocking
you can unlock really beautiful memories
and amazing things like it can also show
you like
quite traumatic upsetting things but
either way like you can learn from it i
think
you know what i did this morning is the
the the founder one of the founders of
the company
a thai um which is leading the charge in
terms of psychedelics they're really
developing about 10 different compounds
in the space
i i said to him i need to get you on
this podcast would you come on and so
he's he's um
as far as i know he's an incredibly
successful biotech guy he's been doing
it for decades and
um he's going to come onto the podcast
and really talk through all of these
things so like ibogaine and psilocybin
and all of that so that would be
interesting fascinating i've been
listening to that one yes but listen
ayahuasca
mushrooms psilocybin if you want to do
it then i've been saying to my all these
people in this room now
i would say let's go and do a retreat
with like a shaman and um
they've told me what the best way to do
it is like the best
retreat the best shaman the best place
i'd love to do something like that
yeah i would be up for it i mean it's
it's a real person it's like personal
growth like you read a lot of books i'm
not well read i wish i had more patience
and
more time and well i wish i had more um
commitment and discipline to reading but
i do i do i'm drawn to it and it always
it almost they say like it will call you
like my dad's i've done an eyewash or
someone in wales and he said
it just calls you like the plant mother
nature like you'll have a calling one
day and it'll be like i'm ready
at the moment we're just sort of
experimenting with the idea of it and
your dad did the psilocybin trial with
imperial so
what was his feedback to you after he
did it yeah i mean it was um
it sometimes takes a little bit longer
to integrate you know you have the
experience and
you know it's in a very controlled room
like it's in a proper like clinical
setting so you're like in a hospital
room and they're holding your hand and
talking through it and
i'm not sure the exact dosage but he got
blasted with a decent dose of psilocybin
um and yeah you know he saw some things
and it unlocked a little bit of
you know trauma and some visual stuff
that he saw
but again it's just about moving forward
it's about it's about taking what you
see and integrating into your life and
saying
i've had these experiences but how can i
be present today how can i enjoy
my life today and you know with
depression is i don't think it's going
to be cured i don't think you can cure
it like that
because of the way the brain works but
you're going to learn to deal with it
and and spot
the signs and kind of counteract it
quicker um
but yeah he had a positive experience
for sure and he's he's really proud that
he took part because he
he genuinely wants to help people like
he said if if people can come off
chemical antidepressants and be given a
really beautiful natural
um you know natural product that can
actually help them feel happier and
especially for that post-traumatic
stress syndrome disorder like people
dealing with some really
really harsh stuff and they're getting
blasted with you know
antidepressants which are very addictive
and it's like morphine isn't it it's
like it's not even
it's not even like good for you so
they're very addictive as well i don't
think you're going to get the same thing
yeah the side effects are
really really you know crazy um
sometimes
i think that opioids i think the opioids
yeah antidepress i think opioid i think
antidepressants are like opioids
or amphetamines it's one of them it's
like it's basically the drug that you
know you do not want to be taking in a
very small dose but over time it can
real generate real addiction and you see
it in america like the prescription drug
addiction over there is
is really destroying people's lives over
there my next question you would have
heard this on the podcast if you've
listened to the eddie hearn one
uh it's kind of a new question i'm
asking and it's a question i really
really love because i think it gives a
unique sense of perspective
um you're an incredibly busy guy you're
running around at the moment doing this
that and the other you know all over the
place
um if you found out god forbid touch
glass
um that this week was your last week for
whatever reason god forbid or you walked
out here and
you got hit by a truck what what would
you regret
having not done or not doing more of i
really wish i had like this long list of
bucket things i wish i'd done but i'm
i've always even when i was at
university like i would
go traveling in my half term my summer
holidays i always i've always maximized
life to the
at that moment in time you know i've
always i've never kind of i've never
regretted or like
missed out on things i've always
traveled with my friends i've always you
know
done the things i want so if i had a
week left on earth
i wouldn't really regret anything i'd be
proud i'm proud of what i've achieved in
this short time i'm 35 i feel like i've
i've been good i've done some good
things i'd probably bring everyone
together and like throw my wedding party
again because my wedding day was wicked
like
all you know your best friends and all
your mate your mates and we had fun fair
and we had all the food and we were
dancing and
i think i'd try and recreate that if i
knew i had seven days i'd get everyone
together and say look it's my last week
come down let's have another blowout and
have a party um but i wouldn't regret
yeah i just really wouldn't i think
it's a shame to live your life like that
you know regretting and wishing your
child was different wishing
you know you you i've and i've got
friends that kind of live in that
mindset of always looking back and
almost thinking about a moment in time
if they just done it differently they
were like life would have been different
today
but you can't think like that you can't
get stuck between the future and the
past can you because that's really
really depressing
whereas if you actually just think look
i've done what i've done
even the bad things and the times i
wasn't nice or disrespectful like
i learned from it and today i'm a better
person for it a lot of people
when you ask them that question they
reflect on like a lack of balance in
their life they'll say oh god i work too
much i didn't see the kids enough and
and those kinds of things that's
typically what you hear it's like you
know i really wish i spent more time
with this person or
or that person i think if i was to
answer that question i'd probably feel
i'd probably say that i'd say
why didn't i spend enough time with my
family i think the reason is because a
lot most traditional businesses like if
you're a grafter
eddie hearn always on the road always
around the world you know footballers
again
away every weekend they're training
their you know traveling about musicians
away from their family and it's hard for
like you know
stability stability and so they do
sacrifice a lot for that fame and
success whereas
my fame and success has come through an
iphone in my kitchen
so i've really even before lockdown i
filmed all my workouts at home
so i have a great balance where i can do
what i'm doing and be successful but
also leave my phone for two weeks and go
away
and not not worry about it or i can you
know put my phone down like i i spend
quality time my kids every day
i'm adamant about that so i do you know
breakfast i make them breakfast every
day
i have two and a half hours so between
like five and 7 30 where i don't have my
phone
and i do dinner time bath time but story
time like i love it it's like my routine
and i know get one set down i can go
back to work or you know watch a film
but it's having little moments at just
having that structure so that you don't
feel like you've missed out and you
ask them how their day's been and indy's
favorite thing is like she loves cooking
and she loves doing her handwriting so
even just running in there and doing 10
minutes with handwriting with her i mean
she's two years old and she's doing the
alphabet she's
she's got like these dots you follow the
dots and just seeing her
with a shaky hand to like now a month
later she's banging out the a to z and
it's like immaculate
that's that's fun it's amazing so i'm
not missing out on these moments
although
i'm really busy i'm also optimizing my
time with them as well if you know i
mean when you said that
india's really into cooking i thought
she's going to be the next body coach
and then i thought oh god i wonder
if joe would want her to be on social
media oh i don't know i had this
dilemma with rosie you know when i was
bringing out my cookbook my weaning 15
book so i got a book deal and
i was genuinely enjoying that journey i
was learning to win indy for the first
time i didn't know what to do i was
working with a nutritionist
and i shared so much you know we got 50
000 pre-orders and i worked hard for
them pre-orders because i shared
everything you know
i shared the dinner i was it was camera
at breakfast it was camera at lunch it
was indeed you like that darling do
another one of them like
so i shared so much in order to have
that success but now i've kind of
i've just gone a little i just don't
want the phone out during dinner time so
i'm producing less content i'm not
producing as much
recipe stuff because i want to have that
time just with us and i used to just
film every gusto recipe
every recipe was on instagram so yeah
i've had to sort of step back a little
bit and there's no way you're going to
keep your kids on social media it's just
whether they're 10 or 15 they're going
to eventually get it but would you like
to though
if you could there's two buttons in
front of you one of them was she won't
join social media until she's 21 and the
other one was she'll join at 10. oh 100
no if i have if i could have my life
about social media like
i have an unhealthy relationship with it
and i you know i watched the social
dilemma on netflix and i was like i
cannot believe
how addictive we are how these devices
are so well designed i would hunt i know
i wish me rosie and and the kids
weren't on social media but i know i
wouldn't have been the body coach p
which i wouldn't have happened so it's
almost this like
trade off it's like a trade of business
life you want to have the success and
have this amazing life and also reach
millions of people
the only way you can do that is social
media it's not tv it's not radio it's
social media so
it has its pros and cons but i i hope
that i hope that we kind of
we can somehow learn to control this
mental health epidemic that we've got
going on with social media and the
narcissism
of instagram i just hope that we're
trying to go actually you know what that
was cool in
2010 and 2020 but maybe now let's be
more humble let's just be
kinder and let's like share useful
content do you know what i'm trying to
say yeah because it could
you know india she's gonna get she's
gonna get her phone she's gonna open it
on that first day when she's 10 years
old
and she's going to see kylie jenner
in a bikini on a yacht in a louis
vuitton bikini
on a massive yacht looking back at it
with her ass looking perfect and perfect
boobs and a perfect face
and perfect hair and india's gonna stare
down into that phone and think
okay yeah what's my life yeah and it
isn't it's that comparative thing and it
it happens to me like i follow a lot of
instagram accounts and you know
my explore page is basically like
motorbikes or it's you know fitness
models and it
it's like because i'm in that in that in
that kind of atmosphere in that
um world and it does you think oh these
guys are in such good shape you know
i'm looking a bit skinny i'm a little
bit positive like whoever you are you
still start to compare yourself oh god
it affects your confidence whether you
know it subconsciously or not
and you know i wish i was more tanned i
wish i was on holiday i wish i had a bit
more muscle with this i wish i wasn't so
skinny or
i wish i didn't have a little bit of
body fat on my tummy this year because
you
you're just bombarded with these visual
representations so yeah i think
that in that effect it almost like you
can't really stop that
if you if you're looking at it all the
time you can't it's almost like you have
to just
unfollow someone's account you said
didn't you said like unfollow the
accounts that don't serve you yeah
and i've started doing that if i get to
one and i go why did i follow that bang
unfollowed you know what it is as well
so i was
when i wrote my i started writing well i
finished my book now but when i started
writing the book
um people are quite crazy at the time
the title's happy sexy millionaire
and in this one chapter i really focus
in on comparison
and this is a bit of an exclusive and i
go through all of the studies on why we
compare ourselves
to other people and why we compare our
you know our car to someone else's car
and
the conclusion i came to is we're not
actually gonna ever be able to stop
comparing because
our brains are wired that way for
survival they like that's how our brain
works it's
very very lazy if you show someone three
tvs
in a shop an expensive one a middle one
and a a cheap one
statistically people will pick the
middle one because they think
that one's gonna break and it's [ __ ]
that's the cheap one and they think the
expensive one is maybe two flashes so
it's just
if you show them three stakes on the
menu statistically people will pick the
one below the most expensive
yeah you know even i actually when you
come to say that i sort of feel the same
like
i'll be like no i don't i don't need
that you know the wagyu one because
i'm happy with a 20 pound one in the
middle whatever yeah you're right
it extends across everything if i said
to you joe would you rather
um drive 10 minutes to save 10 pounds on
a
200 pound jacket or drive 10 minutes to
save
10 pounds on a 20 20-pound jacket people
go well i'll draw i'll save the 10
pounds on the temp
on the 10-pound jacket and you go why
it's 10 minutes it's going to cost you
to drive and you're going to save 10
pounds
but the rain is just assume it's like
the very
the conclusion yeah what's the summer
because i'd like to know what you're
sharing about that
the conclusion is that our brains are so
so lazy they make such
lazy snap decisions and conclusions
because those snap
decisions helped us to survive when we
were when we were 10 000 years ago
alliance running towards you
you can't [ __ ] like right okay is it
you've got just like so our brain does
it at super speed and
and in the context of social media it's
like i loved my nokia phone
yeah until until the new one the iphone
comes out right
i was the proudest kid in school showing
everyone oh look snake
i can do snake on here yeah but then but
then the minute that same thing which
hasn't changed in value
exists in a world of iphones which is
what social media is it's like
me looking at kylie jenner immediately
even though i haven't changed in value i
am less than
your brain tells you i agree i agree
with that and i i feel that myself
sometimes when i
when i watch that show that the netflix
documentary um the social dilemma did
say all of the guys that created the
products that created the like buttons
all those people said my kids aren't on
social media yeah and that's the alarm
bell it's like saying
you know it's like um that joke of you
know i wouldn't trust an eye surgeon
who's wearing glasses like i'm getting
my eyes laid on saturday by the way but
they say you know don't you know if that
person that created it and that does it
every day is saying to you like
get your kids off social media it's not
good for their mental health and that is
what it is it's not about
it i don't think it kills ambition i
think it just really affects people's
mental health
and their self-esteem sometimes that's
irreversible and you could be like a
young teenager that
has an eating disorder you know all
through your life or
is um is binging or under eating or
you know not respecting your body and
that can really stem from like how you
feel about yourself
right so i i try and use my social media
to obviously promote
healthy food and fitness that's a
positive part of social media
and i think your content is positive i
think some of the quotes that you share
like
they know like the ten things and all
these little sometimes i really want to
go
bang wow like it's just a nice little
light bulb moment so you're using it for
positive and
we have to just always focus on that
focusing the people that are bringing
the good stuff out of it
i think you've probably heard me say
before that my the way i use my
instagram i genuinely believe has like
saved my life a little bit because
i would have before if you scroll down
my instagram right now you'll see what i
was like
oh picture of a lamborghini picture of a
louis vuitton bag
and then at some point when i became a
ceo of a company and i felt a sense of
responsibility not to be that guy
i thought okay so how can i use this
i'll post quotes and because i've done
that for the last like i don't know two
three years
it's meant that when i do have it means
that i don't buy stuff
to post it yeah and i if i'm in a
helicopter going over sri lanka sat next
to my girlfriend which i was
no one will know because i actually
don't have a place to put it
so i'm now making decisions on your
close friends list
i'm so glad i'm on that that's why i get
through your nice villains yeah that's
only there's only 100 people on there
but like
i i don't have a place to put it and so
when i'm making the decision
it's not based on social media because
i'm not gonna be able to tell really
anybody other than like
a couple of my close friends my question
though which is kind of attached to that
is about money something that a lot of
people probably won't talk to you about
now listen it's always uncomfortable
it's uncomfortable
it's just awkward everyone articles come
out like joe buys this much
you know this million pound house it's
like why is that important but i just
know that
people are obsessed aren't they ask what
you want to ask and i'll be honest yeah
so an unavoidable consequence of success
like the thing is the reason why i'm
actually not uncomfortable about asking
you this question
is because if there's anyone on planet
earth on off camera that i know
has the most genuine sincere intentions
it is you
probably of all the people i've met i'm
like i can't think of a guest i've met
who is more sincere about their
intentions
more oh thank you steven you're all
maximum sincerity right so
some people are as well but you're
maximum so um i've got no problem asking
you this question which is an
unavoidable consequence of your success
over the last year previously is money
right it's what
allows you to have a camera to dp with
joe right of course yeah
so this year i mean you've made a lot of
money
right like every year um what role does
money play in your life just be honest
with me
it's a it's that it's that thing of you
know it talk we talk about you know
freedom of time and like
you know owning yeah i've always been
about
time and being with friends and family
so for me it's like it's removed a lot
of stress because when i was a kid i
remember
money was a stressor like we you know we
had um
we we never had food in the house so my
mom would have to go to my nand and we'd
have to get like
borrowed pints of milk and running next
door you know when you're on a council
stay it was quite common you'd go and
ask for a pint of milk or a couple of
i remember asking like a bag of sugar
for our cereal and stuff so i i didn't
have any money growing up
and you know i was on school dinners you
know i was my mum was on
benefit so it was it was all like
iceland two for one buy and get them
free it was crap food and that affects
that affects things as well you know the
food you're eating but i suppose
for me when i started to make money it
was a gradual thing i didn't win the
lottery and wake up a million pounds
you know i i released my online plan and
one person signed up
and then it was 10 and it grew and it
was gradual and so it was a nice way of
becoming like with my followers it was a
nice gradual thing i didn't just jump
off of
love island with two million followers
and have money thrown at me and i think
that does affect your ego differently
and
i think anyone that's young that gets
thrown into the media with money and
fame
it would affect you in a certain way um
so
it definitely allowed me to have more
freedom and to
take care of my family i think i'm not
someone who has been successful and left
people behind
that would make me seriously unhappy
i've helped my brother out i've helped
my dad you know i got my mama house
we've done amazing holidays together
with all the boys you know they know i'm
there if they need me
and and that's that's a nice feeling but
yeah the question is
around motivation around money as well i
feel like as time has gone on i've
become less motivated
by it and i remember that story said
about you're up here and you could have
run down the center and even got 20
grand
i have days that too where i think i
could go and do another gusto post and
10 000 people might sign up or i could
go and film another
workout and it could get two million
views and i have and when i feel like
that
i have to remind myself of like why i do
what i do and and that mission thing
about
there's someone at the end of that
youtube video just waiting for a new
workout and they live in scone for when
they've got no man in their proper skin
and they're waiting for the workout and
i remind myself for that so yeah money
money allows it just allows freedom it's
less stress
and money was always something we always
argue about i think maybe my marriage
i'll be honest is easier because we
don't argue about money and maybe your
mom and dad used to argue about money
like school uniform the new trainers you
wanted the school tripped me on this guy
i remember like going on a school trip
was really hard for mum and dad we
couldn't afford to do the school trip
sometimes and
you know they would always work really
hard and it would you know sometimes i
did sometimes i didn't so
i think having a bit more man in the
bank means there's less pressure
on you as a person and therefore you can
sort of you can go through life a bit
easier but
i had to overcome as we talked about
kind of earlier i had to overcome that
that feeling though like that
[ __ ] if more money isn't gonna have an
impact then what the
hell are we doing steve like what are we
doing here because
you know 16 year old steve told me it
was money was the whole game
and you get more of it get more happy
it's just like that your happiness goes
up with your bank balance your ego
inflate because i i can i can imagine
when you said about you know
i used to go to like china white and
punk and like you know
shoot over there and i never had money i
was skint i was a university kid i had
like 20 quid in my pocket i'd be in
there on a freebie
but i imagine if you had man at that
time you'd be the one with the bottles
spraying it about and all the lights
and all the girls come with the big
flares is that what you were like did it
inflate your egos
you know spend more money i i and i've
got to be as self-aware as i possibly
can be here
i um i don't think it's ever had an
impact on my perception of myself
however i did like i've nev i genuinely
feel
the same opinion of myself as i always
have since i was
three like i've it's never changed i bet
people around you changing like because
they knew steve had the dough and you
were there
to come over i was rolling into clubs
and spending i remember this one club in
manchester called neighborhood they had
this little star next to my name because
i was like the number one spender
and i'd walk in there and get five
bottles of dom praying i didn't think i
was
anything else but i was still doing it
like that's
a really important point to make like
you you hear about these rich [ __ ]
and these like young kids that like
they get all this money then they start
treating people like [ __ ] and they
change all of my friends say to me
you haven't changed at all yeah you just
we're still doing it you just bought
you just i suppose you were like the
facilitator you just you were the fun
how did you
exactly brought people together and you
and you could have the fun and i think
you know
maybe fight a bit more at that time
maybe i would have done this because i
do i mean my thing now is going to a
nice restaurant so i love going to like
zuma or nobu and having a meal my
friends i didn't have that kind of
flashy kind of like nightclub vibe but
you know at the time the thing is
at that time that was what you wanted to
do at that time you don't do it now and
i think if you had fun like it's good
it's all good but yeah money i've got
out my system yeah get out your system
and it's weird because i'd i looked at
those people in the clubs and i'd looked
at rich people and thought
oh god like yeah when i when i become
one of them then i'll be super happy
so then you go and do it i went and got
this massive packing mansion in the
countryside
and i'm sat there like nope yeah spray
the bottles for a year and you're
getting all the bottles free and you're
like okay nope
so when you um when you like when you
you exit and you know or even before
that you've been financially secure for
a long time
has your motivation dropped or increased
because i
at the moment i'm feeling quite
demotivated but i'm more excited by
the legacy and the potential of like
building the body codes to a point that
in 20 years time
i can look back when i'm a bit older and
go i started that i created that company
you know that's
still going do you did you find a really
good question lost motivation because
you're like you know what
i can chill now i ain't got i ain't got
the hustle in me anymore it's a really
good question
and again i've been writing a lot about
motivation lately so i think i've got a
pretty good answer to this
um you know one of the the best sort of
easiest to
answer this question is just referring
to my gym routine i think you might have
heard on the podcast i said in one of
the episodes that every
february march i'm the most motivated
person on planet earth to work out and i
say to myself i'm gonna get i'm
have a great body for summer and then
summer comes
i drop the photo on social media summer
ends and i literally can't bring myself
to the gym because my motivation my why
was anchored to a timeline which is
somewhere in summer and looking good and
so the minute i post and everyone likes
it
it was like i genuinely couldn't get
myself to the gym and i was going like
two times a day before
and this relates to our motive our other
motivations in other parts of our life
like
when you lose when you lose the anchor
with your y which is what you described
after p with joe
yeah you've got to [ __ ] find it again
it's like the gold medalist you've got
to go and find it again and you've got
to re-anchor yourself to something that
hopefully doesn't
have a short-term timeline against it
gary vaynerchuk says the same thing he
says the worst day of my life will be
when i buy the jets it's been his
yeah that's his thing isn't it it's
forever this is moonshot and you you i
didn't hear that before that that term
moonshot is nice because it's like joe
so big don't just do something you know
you can do in six months
do something you think will take you 20
years this is what the conversation we
had right yeah that's what you said and
i went home and i was thinking the same
as it's nikki i said
i love that i love the idea of a
moonshot what's our moonshine he's like
well our moonshot is that
we build the body coach and we have an
exit so that someone comes along and
buys it
and it continues to flourish for years
to come because otherwise
i was the it's like mr motivator smashed
it in the 80s or 90s whatever it was
and i would have just been the body
coach the mr motor of this time
unless i build it to sell and i build it
to sustain itself and grow and
continue to help people and that's
really where my heads are now i think
i've had a shift in my mentality towards
that but i did lose motivation at
several parts of my life and it was
always as i described with the 20k and
email downstairs
it was when i was doing things without
that real
intrinsic deep sense why so when before
social change started i had no
motivation to do any marketing for
anybody or to send emails to anybody and
then search chain starts and i'm going
to the [ __ ] ukraine at 3am in the
morning
i spent what was it i spent 11 of the 12
months last year in hotel rooms happy
driving for this mission of building
this company with super key thing
with people i loved yeah right because
it didn't have to be social media
we had a purpose we had a worthwhile
goal
i was working with people i loved
towards that worthwhile goal
and i felt competent in doing so if you
have those three things like competence
a worthwhile goal and you're working
with people you love yeah and lastly i'd
say
a sense of control like autonomy because
a lot of people don't we have that in
our lives a lot of people working in
factories and other industries don't
have that sense of feeling of autonomy
over their
time and have you got the hustle now
could you like go back and do the eleven
months on the roads too no no
no i remember used to always being in
the airport always rolling that little
wiggly thing around i thought
it must be like no matter how much money
you're making no matter how much money
and how much you're building
there must be an element of loneliness
and that exhaustion where you think i
just need to be
like settled in one place and now you're
in london think you're sticking about
are you gonna hit the road again
um great question and it's something
i've reflected on if you told me now
to fly to the ukraine and do a talk i'd
be like [ __ ] off
i've said this to my assistant i can't
understand where it where the motivation
came from and it's because i've lost it
i've lost the anchor i've quit social
change so
when i re even with this mindset i think
go to
the [ __ ] ukraine and do a talk at 9am
to a bunch of people for an hour
[ __ ] off yeah he lost it i've lost it
because because i've quit so my anchor's
gone and i can't even get myself back
into the mindset
however i will get my anchor back at
some point yeah and i'll find something
else that and i'm not trying to find it
at the moment
yeah just it's nice to slow things i
think the lockdowns helped us
just think we don't need to be on this
hamster all the time like it's alright a
few months of the year like you said you
know
nothing in nature blooms all around like
you can have a couple of quiet months
because you know
you know your event didn't happen i
really wanted to be at that event in
manchester but i'm hoping that happening
i i need to come back it's gonna be huge
yeah i know i mean like you showed me
the music i got me and nicki got mad
like goosebumps just listen to the music
you're gonna play
um but yeah you've got loads of heady i
think it's important to just have these
months where you go
i'm not everywhere at the moment but i
know in six months i've got this great
project and there's your moment to bloom
and that's kind of where my head's at
now rather than like
come on what should we do now let's do
another this let's let's do more of this
i'm like
it's okay to be not busy and not be
successful for a few months
and to create a void in your life that's
what my mentor said to me he's one i
think he was one of
the first investor ever in spotify he
said steve i met him after i resigned
and he said steve listen
it's so tempting to just sort of grab
the bull again and just go and run and
run and run and run
he said but the reason you were
successful before is because you were
really hungry
yeah so he said create a void in your
life resist
the temptations just to run back into
something and just
let it be the concept that's probably
not easy for me
to understand like just the i'm getting
it now though i'm getting it now because
i like i said i've always had like
two books a year i've had a dvd out i've
had merchandise pots and pans you know
protein stuff i've always had something
but actually now i know i need to just
chill out and take some time off because
i can't i don't want to be hammer i
don't want to be selling stuff to some
people all the time
i want to just be get back to my free
content what i'm good at what i start
you know the organic stuff that i
generally started doing in the
beginning because that's when i'm
happiest when i'm getting millions of
views on my youtube channel i love that
i love that people are actually like
doing those workouts it's 15 minutes of
my time
but it's helping someone really
transform their day and so i'll continue
to um
you know push that mission which is to
get people moving and
if it's within this one person a day
like it's enough sometimes i just
reflected them when you said that
i think of one of the conversations we
had in that restaurant which was you
were saying you know i've done the pbj
and what's next and i'm saying i was i
remember saying she's like joe this is a
false peak
because like did i say this yeah i said
i don't think i'm going to achieve
anything in my life that's going to have
more impact because
there may never be another lockdown and
there may never be like 80 million
people in their living room doing my
workouts again but you were like joe
don't be silly there's something else
there's something that has to be like
if you don't you're going to lose it you
can lose motivation so yeah you said the
thing about
the moon shot like imagine eradicating
you know
whatever it may be like going for that
real like still
steve steve jobs or bill gates like
vision of like changing the world
it's exciting it might never happen but
at least have a crack but you have that
you
this is why i refer to it as a false
peak because mountaineers when they're
climbing
they look up the mountain and they see
these peaks and it
because of the perspective when you're
climbing a mountain it looks like the
top
and they stop and they go oh [ __ ] that
was but it's a false peak and i think
for you
this is going to be a false peak because
now you have more power than you've ever
had
so you have this i in my view again no
not telling you live your life you
have a responsibility to you're a
[ __ ] mbe you know everyone knows your
name now and you've got the power
to do things on a global level that even
i'm not sure yet you realize you're
capable of doing
and i think when you realize what you're
capable of then um
you're gonna find a why because listen
you you can't waste the power you've got
you just simply can't and there's a lot
of pain out there there's a lot of
people getting fat
there's a lot of people not eating right
and they need someone that has your
power it's like
it's like you know life is giving you
this this responsibility and gone joe
listen we need you and i think that's
i mean that's enough to get our bed for
every day that is the goal mate and it's
so lovely to hear you say that and i do
believe that we have a purpose and we
have
we have an energy inside us and i bumped
into this guy once on the street in
london and he was
really i think he was a shaman of some
sort and he he he basically put his hand
on my shoulder
he does my workouts and he's like
there's something about you like you've
got an energy there's something pushing
you forward isn't there like
it's more than views and fame and
numbers that there's something inside
yeah like there is it's this energy that
is constantly like just go and film the
work i know you're tired but do it and
it's that that's that thing of giving i
i'm my happiest i'm giving and sharing
and the minute i stop that
even if i sell the body coach you know i
know that that moment will come where i
feel like you know i still need to be
doing what i'm good at and still needs
to be reconnecting and
that is my energy that's that and i
didn't have that i was really lost and
confused until 25. i came back from this
trip to america
i started to become a personal trainer
and it was like i just knew in that
moment this is what i was going to do
and
i've just put all my energy and love
into it since so yeah let's see what we
can do in 2021.
thank you so much for your time joe it's
been an absolute pleasure and i'm super
excited to bring you back on for a third
time once you've conquered the world and
we'll be like
we were sat here and you said this and
then
and uh it's been a pleasure man and i
really do enjoy your podcast i take
little nuggets from it i think you're
always sharing a positive message so
keep doing it
um it's good to see that you're growing
and building and i am i hope this
episode does really well for you
thank you i appreciate you all good luck
thank you for sharing all of your wisdom
and learnings i'm continuing to be
inspired by you i can't wait to see what
you achieve in the next few years now go
and get your moonshot can build a rocket